SKRATTAR DUUUU...     Im just kidding, ok.
Welcome back everybody to Just Cause 4. Why did I say welcome back?
So one of the things they've added to Just Cause 4 and
I absolutely loved is the retract, wait, what is it? The Booster that's right!
He's fine. have a great day sir!
What are you looking at?
Woohoo
Bye-bye. You can do some weird stuff in this game.
Hey, I like your haircut
You grab that and then your grab that
Oh it's not a retracting.
Oh it is.
Why. And go! Ah, damn it
And go! Bye-bye! They also added one of my favorite things which is the balloons, excuse me
Bye-bye! we go together. We ride hard. We die hard this video, please guys
Do not send this video to Voxx, whatever you do.
We're going on an adventure
Pearson cow everybody, the advent... Aw Jesus don't worry, mr. Cow,
just... let's hope we don't run into any bridges. ;)
Oh my god what is happening... what just happened?
Get out of my car, dude! Jesus Christ what's happened?! I didn't even do anything!
Don't run away.
So, can I ride the car, or ? There you go, wow, it's the car with people... The human car
Oh No! Oh No! Hey she's coming back
We grab a bunch of people right?  No... god damn it.
Okay, let's... let's just keep uh... Let's just keep adding people. You...
Wanna join my party? Come on join.
Just walking down the streets, and you're dead, and you're part of the party.
No wait, what does it... Oh god, damn it
Are they dead? Like I can't tell
Now we ride! Well goddamn it. Goddamn it! This always happens.
Yes. Yehehehehes
Hey! hey, hey, hey, hey! Stay up. And now we ride. Oh, yeah.
How're you guys doing back there
*music*
What is wrong with me... Oh yeah. Ohhhhh yeah.
Woohoo!
Oh Yeah! Ah, god damn it. *music stops*
. Who had fun today? I had fun yoday. Wait wait wait, sorry, I just got an idea
What if I put this on the motorbike? No, wait, that's wrong. Okay. God damn it
This is not what I wanted
Wow this car is not nearly fast enough if only there was a way I could make it faster
Get it, get in, get it. That's it, that's it, now we ride.
Oh god, oh god.
come on
eyyy
On the tractor
Get it, get it. Damn it.
See this is how the game was meant to be played, everyone knows this. Here we go.
Hey!
Guys please be careful. There's a crane right there.
Oh, awesome a helicopter. Yay. Let's go boys
Wow, what a ride
Why is the most fun in this game just to terrorize people
And...
Woohoo
What happened? Dude, is that a freaking boat? Oh hell yeah.
Can I Drive it?
Oh my god
*in game carachter says "Alright then."* Alright then but what if the boat could fly as well?
There she goes
there,
there...
Yes
She's flying. I think I'm stuck inside the boat.
I think I glitched myself. God damn it
How could I break the game? That's ridiculous
See you later boat you've done well
Now can I ride a pig?
Nope, that just kicks him. Sorry.
Wait, that's wrong. Sorry. Sorry
Sorry, sorry, I did it wrong. I did it wrong. I did it wrong. Goddamn it.
Oh, yeah
That's what I'm freakin talking about. Guys, please, I'm just... It's a video game. Alright, I'm sorry
Wait, they have fighter jets. I need that. I need it
Oh... Oh, Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Ohhhhh!
Oh my god
What's up, man?
That's mine now.
Let's freakin do this.
WOOOOHHOOOOOO
Oh my god, this is where the fun begins
*laughs*
Ho oh. Oh god the helicopter is spinning.
*says the name of Christ in vain*
Kay I'm fine. Why would you need a helicopter?
When you can make your own! God, damn it.
Oh my god. Hey, look it's my Nissan everybody, remember that one?
Get in, get in, that's it, spin, spin like you've never... there it is
This is the un-modded version of the game by the way.
Oh my god, we're gonna create a...
Ohhhhhhhhh
What am I even doing? I'm not even playing the game
Shut up, this is how I play games, god dammit.
Oh my god, what is wrong with this guy?
Can they not? Oh my god! Well, I can't. Oh there it is there. Okay, okay. Alright. So now
Just reverse
Let's reverse, now, let's just reverse
Alright we're doing a shortcut we're doing a shortcut we're doing a live I'm doing a live everybody I'm doing a live. Ok  Abort, abort abort
And I'm alive! What the hell is happening there, what is that?!
*laughs for no reason*
Why can't I do that?
But Bush, you miss the truck!
I'm not aiming for the truck
Just kidding. It was a joke. Sorry. I'm kidding. I'm joking. Let's just land.
And now a perfect landing
Executed by the perfect pilot.
Alright, I need to slow down. We need to "speed down"
Oh, they have a... they have a...
[I dont think he ever finished that sentence]
Oh control speed setting, ok got it.
Alright, Let's land this baby.
Let's land this baby flawlessly
[waiting for video to get to 10 minutes]
It's a fucking art to fly, people don't realize.
[Brad probably didn't want to cut this out so he wouldn't have to put A.S.S. in the outro]
That's just ridiculous. Okay. Well that was Just Cause 4 hope you guys had fun watching. Smash like for more epic gameplay
don't tell media production sponsored by and thank you
and Merry Christmas!
You want pyramids we got them? Oh, you're into castles, huh? We got you covered baby. You want some pets? easy
We got it all
This game is still relevant. Goddamn it